[Aplausos]
Es la primera vez que las enfermeras
británicas salen a la calle desde la
fundación de su sindicato
nos hemos visto empujados a esta
situación ahora mismo estamos en huelga
y Habrá más huelgas tenemos que
reconocer que no estamos aquí por
elección y que no hemos hecho esto por
capricho fácil
piden una subida hasta la real de
alrededor del 19% para compensar años de
carencias argumentan que los bajos
salarios se traducen en escasez de
personal y en una atención precaria para
los pacientes el gobierno conservador se
ha mostrado implacable prometiendo
legislar para reducir el poder de los
sindicatos y negándose a reabrir las
negociaciones me traen en una habitación
me dicen que puedo hablar de cualquier
cosa menos de salarios cierran sus
libros no ponen ni un céntimo marrón más
sobre la mesa y se marchan y dan la
espalda a la profesión
un curso que tuvo también lugar el
miércoles en el parlamento entre el
líder de la oposición taborista quiere
estar mejor y el Primer Ministro
señor presidente que las enfermeras
estén en huelga es una vergüenza para
este gobierno en lugar de mostrar
liderazgo está jugando con la salud de
la gente
si él cree que es justo que se cumplan
las reivindicaciones salariales del 19%
que lo diga lo que es débil señor
presidente Es que él no es lo bastante
fuerte para enfrentarse a los sindicatos
el Reino Unido sumido a una crisis del
coste de la vida vive un momento de dar
atención desde los ferroviarios y el
servicio postal Hasta la policía de
fronteras se enfrenta a una oleada de
huelgas este invierno